[Music]
samuel l.jackson clarifies comments he
made about casting black British actors
in african-american roles there are a
lot of British black British actors at
work oh all the time so I kind of wonder
what would that movie have been with an
American brothers who really understands
that in a way you actually take a
snippet of what somebody says and you
make a headline out of it you listened
to the conversation you know turning to
another thing you know I totally respect
and love all those UK guys that come
over here and work and I understand
they're coming here it gives them a
unique opportunity to advance their
career and hopefully go back home and
create opportunities for their friends
and other guys and let them know that
they can come here and they can't
succeed to be known black minds wanna
you know as far as you know we talking
like get out and I've know Daniel for a
very long time
I knew Daniel when he was a young writer
actor in the UK you know I had literally
introduced her to his agent so I'm
looking forward to y'all coming over
here you know hopefully I run into you
on set somewhere we can talk it out we
can work it out you know it's all good
[Music]